hey everybody its charlie so the actor
that plays the night king did a big
spread in preview of his character
during season eight he dropped a couple
really big teasers so we'll break it
down there's a new round of the book
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video the new preview that they
dropped for him has a couple Easter eggs
in here so everybody's wondering about
his weapon here this is the ice sword
that he's been using for the last couple
of seasons we just haven't gotten a
really good look at it but you see it is
far back a season six episode five when
he's assaulting the three-eyed Ravens
tree like you see him hold it up here
when he walks down he kills him with it
his brand is running away with Meera
even though you can't actually see what
symbol is on that doorknocker because it
could be a lion's mane and that could be
King's Landing but I think more likely
because they don't want to give away big
spoilers is that it's a shaggy wolf's
head and it's at the gates to Winterfell
and it's like you know wolf at the gates
because as legend tells the knight King
was once a stark of Winterfell so it's
kind of like he's coming home even
though he obviously isn't human anymore
there's still a human part to him as the
actor says so there's some really cool
information that he gives Annie talks
about a very specific target that he has
during season eight so we just broke
this down top 9 style the actor's name
is Vladimir verdict he actually took
over from the previous actor that played
the night king during hardhome he talks
about the other things that he's done on
Game of Thrones and how he wound up
playing the night king so his first big
role as a white Walker was actually
playing the white Walker the Jon Snow
crossed swords with and then smashed
during the hardhome battle while there
was another actor playing the night king
he says he's not totally sure why Dan
and Dave picked him to become the next
night king but they said that after that
episode they approached him before
season 6 and said do you want to play
the night king and of course he said yes
he's also been a stuntman on the TV show
doing other big scenes so he says he's
done a lot of horse Falls fire drops
high falls sword fights he said he
doubled for Arthur Dayne during the
Tower of joy fight scene in during
season 6 when Daenerys dragons are
burning the Y's mastership you have
three dragons on that one boat he said
that he was one of the people jumping
off the boat into the bay number eight
he talks about how the different
directors want him to show different
sides of the night
more cold inhuman stuff and then other
scenes where he's a little more
human-like he says all the different
directors that have directed him while
he's playing the night King have a
different vision of how they want him to
play the character Dan and Dave want him
to be more like a cold man some of the
other directors wanted to show that
there's still some human side to him
there even though we've never heard him
speak and obviously we haven't seen him
emote that much but the way he says it
here they actually do want him to have
some expressions on his face sometimes
that make him seem more human
number seven he explains what the night
king wants photon quote he says somebody
made him the night king nobody knows who
he was before a soldier part of the
nobility like we say legend tells he's a
North man probably a stark of Winterfell
the actor goes on to say he never wanted
to be the night King I think he wants
revenge
everybody in this story has two sides a
bad side and a good side the night King
only has one side a bad side
number six he also says that he has a
very specific target that he wants to
kill you'll find out who that is he also
refers to the moment that he had with
Jon Snow in hardhome when Jon Snow was
in the boat reacting to him in the night
King raises his arms as if to challenge
Jon Snow come at me bro and then raises
all those whites up he says there's a
similar and even stronger moment between
Jon Snow in the night king during season
eight I'll address both of those things
in a second because we know that he has
a specific target it's probably not Jon
Snow because he mentions him within this
same sentence and that would be a
spoiler and they don't allow them to
give away spoilers and official
interviews like this number five they
asked him what his all-time favorite
night King scene is that he's played and
he says that that happens during season
eight we haven't seen it yet
he doesn't say what it is exactly
obviously but early theory because he
has a history as a stunt man on the TV
show it's probably a big really cool
action scene during a big battle like
either the 3-way giant dragon battle in
midair or an all-out pitch battle on the
ground with him swinging his eye sword
through anything that gets in his way
the most fun scenes for actors to play
tend to be scenes that they have with
other actors in frame like when Emilia
Clarke talks about her favorite scenes
on Game of Thrones she doesn't usually
talk about when she's doing cg green
screen for drogon flight scenes play
during season 7 episode 4 all really
cool Daenerys riding drogon scenes over
the
most part when actors filmed those
scenes they're not quite as fun because
they're by themselves with a giant green
screen on a really huge looking pommel
horse device so that's why when the
night King actor is talking about his
favorite scene it's probably him on the
ground in a really big battle scene more
to that though number four the nigh king
aerial dragon fights versus ground
assault so past few seasons we've seen
the character being relatively silent a
power player in the back that delegates
a lot of the ground assaults to his
white Walker generals and their hordes
of whites now that he's got Viserion
he's much more powerful and he's
actually doing things he brought the
wall down obviously he's going to
continue using vissarion but speculating
that it would also make sense that they
somehow get him off that dragon or
either a kill vissarion so that he's
forced to fight on the ground again but
then the obvious payoff would be you
finally get to see what the night king
is like in battle no one has crossed
swords with him yet he's never come into
proximity with anyone besides brand in
that special vision and if anyone is
actually going to cross swords with them
it'll probably be Jon Snow or the other
people that are wielding Valyrian steel
because I think the whole idea with the
dragon glass is that it's just as
effective at killing White Walkers it
was also used in the creation of the
night king when he was at this weirwood
here with the children of the forest but
think about it this way balerion steel
is probably much stronger than dragon
glass dragon glass spears that these
unsullied in the Knights of the Vale are
probably wielding are still just giant
wooden poles with dragon glass on the
end the White Walkers ice Lance's and
the knight kings ice sword would
probably - those two pieces pretty
quickly Valyrian steel weapons as we've
seen going back to hardhome are much
stronger against the White Walkers
weapons so if anyone actually gets to
fight him on the ground is probably
going to be one of the people with
Valyrian steel somebody tell Gendry to
borrow one of the dragons and use the
dragon fire to smelt some Valyrian steel
with some dragon glass mixed in Samwell
really needs to talk to brand about
forging Valyrian steel I'm sure that he
could dig up the plans for that I get a
lot of questions doesn't brand know how
to smelt Valyrian steel George R Martin
hasn't revealed that secret yet but it's
probably a combination of castle-forged
steel mixed with dragon glass smelted
with dragon fire which is much hotter
than regular fire and maybe even some
blood magic in play number three the
night King's special scene that he talks
about with
snow their standoff 2.0 moment is
probably on the ground during the big
Battle of Winterfell that we've seen the
trailer after they destroyed a massive
portion of white sand maybe a white
Walker to Jon Snow and Daenerys are
going to be losing a lot of their forces
Dothraki unsullied Knights of the Vale
the knight King is probably gonna do
something similar to what he did at
hardhome where he raises Jon Snow and
Daenerys as former allies as whites to
replenish his ranks and it becomes this
big horror moment when all their allies
turn against them so to speak maybe even
one of the bigger secondary characters
or to get turned into whites because
unless they get rid of all the whites
they're not gonna have a whole lot of
time to turn around in the middle of an
ongoing ground assault and burn the
bodies of the dead because that's what
you need to do otherwise they're all
just fodder for the night keen to raise
back up as whites
number two the Nike actor says he wants
revenge for being turned into the night
king he never wanted to become this as
the end of season six it seems like most
of the children of the forest are
already dead so he's taken his revenge
against them so the next logical step
villain logic is that he would turn on
the people that led to the circumstances
for his creation which would be humans
think about the metaphor this way the
children of the forest created the night
keen to end a never-ending war with
humans who they perceived to be
destroying their sacred weirwoods
destroying the planet so he's already
taken his revenge against them for
turning him into this but the next
logical step to complete the metaphor
would be to eradicate humans for
starting the war in the first place even
though that goes back thousands and
thousands of years but the really big
thing number one his main target that he
teases he specifically needs to kill
during season eight probably not Jon
Snow like I said just because he
mentions him in the same sentence when
he's talking about that an HBO would
prevent them from giving away big
spoilers like that so you automatically
have to discount Jon Snow and it's
probably not gillies son little Sam
people have asked about that since the
end of season 4 the reason why I don't
think that little Sam is super super
important is just because the night king
could turn any human baby into a white
Walker and that's all Craster was doing
which is giving him people to replenish
his ranks of white Walker generals
that's why early prediction has a
specific target that he needs to take
down is bran stark and possibly the
Winterfell heart tree because bran is
one of the only people we know of with
the information about how to unmei
the night king now that the children of
the forest are gone he's like the last
major threat because he has so much
information going back to the beginning
of all this
yes Daenerys as dragons can probably
slow him down injure him with dragon
fire in Valyrian steel dragon glass
might also be able to wound him but I
think that stopping him
permanently is way more difficult Issac
hempstead right also revealed that bran
stark during season eight is gonna be
much more human-like he's gotten used to
his abilities so less turnip more
regular person that's capable of
communicating with other people the only
reason why I think it would be important
for the knight King to destroy the
Winterfell Hart tree is is because
that's probably where brands abilities
are strongest also there was a weird
wood present when the children of the
force created the night king implying
that it's a necessary component of
getting rid of him there are a lot of
you that asked about the Isle of faces
on the books like would the night king
want to destroy the Isle of faces
because in the books it's a very
powerful place for the children of the
forest it's where they use their magic
to smash the arm of Dorne during the war
with the first men even though that was
unsuccessful more people came to
Westeros eventually when they eventually
signed the truce with the first men the
pact that they signed was signed on the
Isle of faces and that's when they
carved all the faces onto the weirwoods
there so that the gods would be able to
see their pact
unless bran specifically mentions the
Isle of faces in the first episode or
two I don't expect the concept to be a
big thing on the TV show during the
final episodes I could talk all day
about the Isle of faces and the children
of the forest but just remember that the
TV show is probably gonna skim past a
lot of really big book stuff so when we
actually get to the episodes I will talk
about specific Easter eggs if they do
mention things from the books let me
know in the comments though who do you
think the target is that the night king
says that he's going after during season
eight and what will happen is there'll
be more bonus videos over the weekend
leave your requests in the comments
below
congratulations to Terminator 360 you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here for my golden company trailer
video and click here to rewatch the Game
of Thrones season 8 trailer of billion
times thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight